welcome to this video playing swap from
Germany am moolah international master
Bolin I am yeah I keep saying em [ __ ]
let's the German pronunciation ok we
have a scotch game playing my my pet
line here that can't resist if I can't
resist to play the Queen to do edge form
um let's think about this um 86 this is
one possible way to play d6 engine
possibly Knight f6 later not 97th yeah
let's see what he's coming up with
castling I had a tournament game once in
this line i haven't-- in two games and
this is this Queen edge for move is a
bit there's a bit dicey ok well this is
not not very critical to be honest um I
can just take it probably I should also
take it now I can play Knight to f6 se5
now g4s leading nowhere um 94 or not
nudge 495 is a very typical way to play
and I guess out mmm yeah I can just play
Queen of 6cm yeah probably
I want to get out of this we're to self
pin I wonder did I have some tactic
maybe some crazy tactic probably not um
okay I can just play 95 yeah yes is it
possible to play with with them g5 you
know something what about h 5 h 5 h form
i guess this is a means that tries to to
justify the same this piece maneuvers
right each five Bishop e2 is threatening
a form and I'm not sure I want to play
g5 in this position maybe I maybe I
could have played that but but h4 is
also interesting this this IDM while
getting this idea in the in the mix also
95 Bishop e2 h4 and g5 trying to make
sure the night on e5 is staying there
are interesting very interesting move
hmm yeah it's g fiber move or is this
this is totally totally insane i'd like
to fight for the e5 square very much now
he plays h3h3 i know i can take one F
for the temple okay then let's let's go
the only move that the trillium tries to
tries to justify my am my previous moves
and I'm not sure that it is bad I mean
it's certainly interesting if I exchange
G against f porn I get the e5 square for
the night yeah this was one possible way
to do it I wonder should I start with h
4 or taking I guess each FOIA so that
after Queen F 3g takes it takes with the
Queen looks that looks more precise than
taking on their forum why should I take
with the Queen actually hmm I don't know
pawn takes a five night XD file is
probably another not not a problem we
will get them probably Quint x f4 will
be planned anyway okay so i can take and
play the 935 watches which is rather
rather nice he will probably try to
exchange my my night with Knight to f3
don't think the resume and there is a
way to to prevent it maybe I can
initiate some quick play on the
queenside like 85 f for Knight f3 I can
just let him take but ok there is a
weakness on edge form it's not to be
underestimated
but still let's assume this it should be
six maybe a five a for coming at some
certainly okay for black him nothing um
nothing brilliant after Knight f3 out
seven ig6 by the way which I initially
didn't see at all night g6 traps the
rook that's important and Bishop e6 and
was a good move anyway because I want to
control not sure what age three does
keeping the pawn edge for maybe try to
fix this may be king edge to ng3 coming
something like that possible
okay now is preparing night of three I
guess yeah should I take it or should I
what should I do can also let him take
let him take probably check probably not
a very good idea a form a 40x look bit
to something like that not sure that is
that this is any good maybe you look a
high h5 intending it a FOIA also has
before but ok this is a good move to
activate the rook I guess I was thinking
walks in five also I Scott bishop you
too it's got Bishop e2 time warning hmm
a form that's also before but I've got
III and tough tough endgame not not sure
what's the most precise way to play this
don't like to give up the edge for porn
but I've got some selectivity going with
the rooks p3 hangs and c3 hangs not this
is very difficult active rook my take I
take I'm going to get pinned but I can
take f1 Roxy five that's probably
probably not a good idea
take ya King 62 I don't check I didn't
see g4 oops maybe i'm just about to save
it I like my fencing no one time I
didn't really look at the clock of
course it's a draw I normally would
offer I didn't see the clock at all I
was just worried that that I saved the
game with with those pawns I didn't I
overlooked g45 but i think it's just
it's just just about a draw right yes um
jam ok I had the better end game here
but I couldn't really couldn't really i
converted before let's let's look a bit
at the same game the compass givin me
dis ting dad which which I tend to
believe but what exactly did I do wrong
c4 takes takes takes and he took here
rook b2 is also right Bishop everyone I
the comp really wants to take ok maybe
maybe because of d5 as this may be the
reason no just just going back yeah
maybe the sea pawn is so I was I wasn't
really thinking about it because i have
this if this amazingly ugly-looking
tripled porn but jam yeah it is tripled
but it's also quick the sea porn in
kinetis is a bad judgment by me man this
is just good for why I for black not
even good probably winning I will I will
I will get this promoted
and that's excellent am also the rook on
edge voice is on a very unlucky spot
because you really want the H pond to
run and we can look at this a bit here
this is useless and yeah I'm just I'm
just I'm just promoting this thing or
yeah I'm invading oops not here to this
invading with the king or maybe taking
the pawn this is lack could have really
taken yeah this is the big mistake
around here he's probably saved himself
calm still thinks I'm almost winning
here I can as okay okay okay I made a
mistake here again but ok it's 20
seconds something here this this is good
check and then i get i get to go to
everyone and just keep this pawn and
here i mean I'm an excellent shape I get
rock ff2 coming taking on g2 a black
probably wins this yeah the the whole
thing if we go back a bit this end game
is it's just a bit better for black
because of this fantastic night I have I
have more possibilities to to provoke
weaknesses I've got the beef I'll Bishop
has a nice place only six it's nothing
decisive but black is slightly more
comfortable and white can easily phone
astray I don't think that this was a
very good move probably not sure what
you should do however now my ideas are
something like this see 5 a-5 a for
attacking the queenside his Bishop only
have one is a pretty pretty dumb piece
you know okay thanks for watching